[Music]
President Trump is heading for
Minneapolis right now where he will host
a campaign rally later this evening
again you'll see that right here on Fox
News Channel
our latest Fox News poll indicates
despite the impeachment rumblings the
president is holding the line with
Republicans heading into 2020 17 percent
of Republicans said they would like to
see someone else at the top of the
ticket next year 77 percent of GOP
voters want to keep the president
president Trump right there
correspondent Kristen Fisher is in
Minneapolis tonight with a preview of
tonight's event big crowd it looks like
could even christen good evening bread
this is president Trump's first campaign
rallies since Democrats launched their
formal impeachment in parade and he's
doing it in the deep blue city of
Minneapolis
this is Democratic congresswoman Ilhan
Omar's district the city's Democratic
mayor is trying to get the Trump
campaign to pay about half a million
dollars in security costs security fees
associated with this rally and there are
big protests planned outside this arena
tonight in fact some of them have
already started but the Trump campaign
believes that this is a state that
President Trump can win in 2020 he lost
it in 2016 by less than two points so
this time around they're investing a ton
of money and manpower into Minnesota the
campaign has already put 20 staffers on
the ground with plans for nearly 800
before Lexington Republican won over
80,000 people requested tickets it'll be
totally sold out they have a line now
that's many blocks long and here's a
look at the line that President Trump
was just referring to thousands are now
inside the Toyota Center waiting for the
president you can hear them cheering now
they'll be introduced by the vice
president who will be meeting right
before the rally with the head of the
minneapolis police union after the city
banned off-duty officers from wearing
their uniforms at tonight's rally it's
something President Trump will likely
mention tonight along with his feuds
with the city's mayor and congresswoman
Ilhan Omar but the big thing to watch
tonight is how President Trump defends
himself against this impeachment inquiry
Brett he's made this case over and over
on Twitter and in front of reporters but
this is the very
to hear him make that case in front of
his supporters right true campaign-style
I'm sure Kristen Fisher live in
Minneapolis Kristen thanks